pawn from promoting and
just say queen and knight sometimes can
cause some mischief yeah so dude it does
that the only way to stop that pawn from
becoming a new queen was to give up your
bishop for it um so we now see black
ahead again on material black has an
extra bishop two bishops against a one
lonely knight
and also lots of annoying checks yeah
unfortunate for
duda here because uh have you given up
yes he has he resigns wow two zero four
magnus carlsen in this match rushing off
minus crossing but this is a devastating
start for young christoph duda a great
start for the world champion the winner
of this match
wow look at magnus uh rushing off here
how impressed are you with him now david
yeah he's looking sharp he's looking
strong he's
very confident as well playing quickly
that's the key for magnus carson in the
past when he struggled it's maybe
because of time but uh yeah he's looking
like the world champion essentially okay
we're not looking too happy here he's uh
he was skirting on the edge of defeat
we do know whenever he's not too happy
about his play